my name is henna I'm I'm not hired by
particle I'm just a more active
community member working on the product
so I do some my fixes for the a common
lied to and stuff like that but I i I'm
a hardware guy so I don't really know
much about Java scream and stuff but I'm
gonna shave you guys what you can do so
I hope you guys can make use of the hard
way that you have they got you in the
registration so there's my hand dollar
name you can find in the forum as well
if you need more help so I'm just gonna
show you the hardware that we are gonna
work with oh sorry I forgot to mention
that mariko is an IOT company so this
all of the Internet of Things
development kit which is the middle of a
lot of API endpoints so you guys should
be very familiar with it so I can run
the device here because i think the
mighty puppy blocks the part that we
need to talk to so i'm gonna send it to
the device on the writing the one on the
right side that is running somewhere
else in my home okay so the two on the
left are like cellular versions but you
can spin too they're using the same
endpoint okay so um let me do the demo
so what I'm gonna do first it's let's
look at this one here so one of the
developer for party co-wrote d-sub web
app basically so it shows you the let me
just refresh so it shows the devices
that are online my car right now so you
see three devices online and um let it
load so I guess you guys are familiar is
open source you can take a look at this
one so these are some of the functions
that are available the device that we
coded so you can call it based on an API
endpoint so let me give you an example
so let's say I have two device running
now here so I want to know what's the
battery percentage left right now so i
just hit update here
and your we get a value so the battery
is like ninety two percent right now so
everything is done by unaware if I know
you're not hot web developer you can
interact with a hardware device so
that's the beauty of using the
particular hardware key so let's do
something more interesting so I have a
code right now over here is using the
online web ide so what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna send this code publish it or
rather flashy to the device in my house
and it's gonna do a publish message
every 1.5 seconds so I guess you guys
are pretty familiar with the Popish
subscribing in in your Chavez people so
let me just flash the code here so i got
even sent to the server compound and
what sitcom pulse it sends over to the
device so it is our flesh successful
they have a dash both feature here as
well so you see a series of servers SS
events so you can see right now over
here the device is actually publishing
the event so these are some things that
you can do you can check out the
documentation as well so it's as things
that you guys are really familiar with
like API jason taylor coming back and
stuff like that so i hope you guys will
go home and explore the device play
around with it and do some cool stuff so
I'm some place that you can go to we
have the forum so in the forum there's a
lot of like project sharing and stuff
like that you can go and get some
project ideas I'm going east of your
hardware body and get them to do
something for you and make something
interesting with JavaScript so I hope
you guys had a better understanding of
the highway there was even out the
innovation and hope you have some fun
Thank You Kenneth
you